this might be the biggest episode of the
season yet with a huge caleb reveal
frankie's identity and maeve's
resurrection we're not going to waste
any of your time let's get into it just
like episode 3 started with a whisper
from a loved one so too does episode
four caleb reels from his fly attack but
notice that there are no flies here have
they already disappeared or is that
because they never existed in the first
place we get to see what happened at the
lighthouse a place we've seen in maeve's
flashbacks this was filmed in cabo they
are here to destroy the last remnants of
rehoboam you may remember this place
from season 3 in which sorak and his
brother would create and test early
versions of it of note here is caleb
asking maeve what they'll do after this
war is over she assumes they'll go back
to their regular lives but caleb wonders
what that looks like for them i can't
help but think there are some feelings
these two have for each other that have
never been expressed they blow the place
up but during their escape caleb is shot
fortunately maeve can hack into caleb's
limbic system via the drip installed on
the roof of his mouth we've seen other
characters have this such as gerald in
season 3 who would use it to help him
fall asleep and william who did not have
the most peaceful installation of one
usually this drip requires a dissolving
limbic tab in which you are then
transported to a happy or peaceful scene
but it looks like maeve's powers can
hack this device allowing her to
transport him to a happy place where he
can feel what freedom is really like for
me this freedom is with her daughter in
a tranquil field and that tree looks an
awful lot like the one we saw in the
sublime with bernard we don't know much
about what happened between their escape
from the lighthouse and caleb's arrival
at the hospital nor if maeve's power
extends beyond gaining access to his
limbic system can she upload his
consciousness for example similar to how
host data can be transmitted to these
grey spheres but before we get any
answers caleb is awoken by charlotte
he's had this weird sensor thing put
over his head which it appears charlotte
used to access his neural diagnostics
the parasitic flies have entered his
body making him a carrier allowing
charlotte to use this acoustic device to
control him she's wanting humanity to
pay for what it did to the hosts and her
plan involves using the park to turn
humans into these carriers meanwhile
maeve learns that william is now a host
and that her friends like clementine are
gone this likely means under his control
as we've already seen her do his bidding
maeve runs back to the control room
where we get a glimpse of the tower or
perhaps some earlier smaller version of
it which we'll later see looming over
new york william tells maeve that she
can't access his mind like she can other
hosts charlotte has made some upgrades
but maeve isn't hacking into his brain
she's hacking into the machine letting
off a huge auditory blast that allows
caleb to take charlotte hostage and for
them to escape if she can do this on
this device does that mean she can do it
on the larger one in new york for those
wondering maeve's host idea is the same
as seasons one to three however there
have been instances where it's been
different in the past but this is the
main one that's been used maeve refers
to charlotte as dolores's dark side and
she's right this charlotte is one of
delores's copies that has gravitated
towards dolores evil side something we
really saw manifest in season two
speaking of dolores or should i say
christina she's overslept something her
roommate maya thinks is odd and that
might be because this goes against her
loop every time we've seen christina she
pretty much does the same thing every
day wakes up at the same time goes to
work comes back and is pressured into
going on a date when she last deviated
from this it was tracked by her boss
well she's deviated yet again and spent
most of the night painting the tower on
one of her paintings which appears to be
a view from her balcony this drawing
looks similar to the one seen with the
homeless man and at the psychiatric
hospital her roommate mentions having
nightmares that felt real about her and
her family being swarmed by flies during
a picnic this hints that these flies
overtook the world and that everyone in
new york is a carrier under charlotte's
control keeping up with the black and
white theme you'll see christina's
closet filled with black and white
clothing just like in episode 1 she had
to choose between black and white shoes
in the far future bernard watches these
drones overhead because he's seen the
outcome of the world while in the
sublime he's not too concerned about
being spotted these two finally have
names the woman who picked up bernard
and stubbs is referred to as c and this
guy j the two butt heads c wants to
follow bernard to the supposed weapon in
the desert while jay doesn't trust them
he believes there's something more
important a female outlier the last time
we heard the term outlier was in season
3 to refer to anomalies like caleb these
are people that rehoboam could not
accurately predict my hunch is that this
outlier is dolores and i'll explain why
i think that is in my teaser trailer
spoiler section at the end of the video
c goes out on a limb believing bernard
to be telling the truth jay allows her
to go on their treasure hunt but takes
stubs as collateral should anything
happen we also get a brief moment with
sea's lover odina a name which means
divine creative inspiration back in the
1920s park maeve knocks out a cop
looking for that notorious bootlegger
hector who we saw maeve kill last
episode she steals his cuff so caleb no
longer has to hold charlotte using his
shard of glass that's gotta hurt they
have to make their escape quick before
everyone in the park is infected their
plan is to make it right outside the
park's boundary where caleb's men can
extract them charlotte chides maeve
saying she could have lived if she
hadn't been so sentimental referring to
her tapping into the grid to check up on
caleb an event which alerted charlotte's
men to her the telephone poles have been
equipped with these audio transmitters
dispatching orders to the carriers now i
combed over all the new york scenes from
the first three episodes to see if i
could find any of these transmitters and
the closest thing i found was this
honestly it could just be a regular
light and that the giant tower sends out
these transmissions with caleb and maeve
on the run the park guests are
instructed to take them down this was
likely done by william who survived that
blast a few moments ago bonus points if
you caught temperance clementine here
during their escape however caleb under
the control of the sound almost kills
maeve but he's stabbed right before it
happens remember that in these parks
hosts can't harm humans just like we saw
caleb get shot last episode and it
didn't affect him but there's nothing to
say a human can't harm a human so this
is likely why this carrier was able to
stab caleb and when he's shot by maeve
you don't see any blood come out because
maeve is a host and her gun here
wouldn't work on a park guest as we
follow bernard and c we get a glimpse of
the construction site on the top left
corner they've brought with them this
giant fan which kind of looks like an
airplane engine they're interrupted
however by some sort of drone one which
narrowly detects bernard who finds an
insect in the sand one of his visions he
had while in the sublime this is yet
another sign that he's on the right
track maya helps christina with some
lipstick the same kind she gave her in
episode 1. christina drops it and it
rolls towards teddy just like the can in
westworld not only that he says the line
don't mind me
just trying to look chivalrous don't
mind me
[Music]
just trying to look chivalrous we saw
teddy at the end of episode 1. we can't
be sure but he may have been the one to
save christina from peter and left her
this drawing of the maze outside her
apartment christina is teddy's date and
she feels like she's known him lifetimes
and maybe i read into things too much
but her cocktail glass looks a little
bit like the tower it's even fashioned
with a toothpick spire unfortunately
that's about it for christina's
storyline in this episode and we're
gonna have to wait a little bit longer
to find out exactly why and how teddy
has arrived caleb's stab wound reminds
him of maeve leaving him when he was
shot he doesn't remember her being by
his side for weeks likely because he was
unconscious and on death's door she
leaves him with his future wife wade who
fixes his iv suggesting this is his
nurse and this is how they met this is
the something real maeve wants for caleb
we also see that caleb has that facial
scar here the writers wouldn't have put
this in unless it plays some sort of
importance like it being used as a
distinguishing feature between multiple
caleb's maeve caleb and their prisoner
charlotte make their way to the delos
park expansion site the same location
bernard is in in the future maeve fends
off william while caleb contacts his men
for extraction remember that his phone
was taken away in episode 2. charlotte
tries to control caleb one last time but
caleb overcomes it and shoots william he
manages to disobey her but we never
really find out how he just says he has
something that she doesn't however in
the end it doesn't really matter as we
find out that caleb died 23 years ago
and is one of 278 copies that charlotte
has created as part of a fidelity test
you may remember in season 2 149
versions of james delos senior were
created in the hopes of making a human
host hybrid that would be
indistinguishable from its human self
allowing him to essentially be immortal
this was never perfected and all copies
of him were incinerated so it looks like
charlotte has brought this idea back
using caleb as the test subject just why
charlotte is wanting to do this is
unclear if we're to believe her caleb's
real body was shot and killed shortly
after maeve blows up the explosives
around the construction site taking
william down with her unlike william
however maeve cannot be recreated into
another copy caleb tells charlotte he
won't let frankie grow up in a world
controlled by her and then the next shot
is of c c is frankie caleb's daughter 23
years in the future this is why the
episode is called generation loss a
double entendre referring to generations
lost and how certain technology loses
its quality after being copied over and
over again maybe c's name is a nod to
the first letter in caleb's name bernard
digs up maeve this is the weapon he's
been talking about is she the weapon
because she can control different types
of technology or did her connection with
caleb those years ago allow her some
kind of access into charlotte's network
allowing it to be taken down after
caleb's revelation he awakens in new
york across from charlotte we'll later
see him run out of the olympiad building
the same place christina works but any
attempt at escaping is fruitless
everyone here is under charlotte's
control as we'll see her stop everyone
just like humans could to hosts in
westworld hale has won and the world has
become hers now it seems the only one
who can stop her is bernard but for that
we'll have to wait for more episodes now
here is your warning for teaser and
trailer spoilers where we'll look at
some of the shots we haven't yet seen
and what may happen going forward stubbs
appears to be in new york we last saw
him being taken by jay as collateral in
their search for this outlier suggesting
that this outlier may be based somewhere
in the city hence why i think it could
be christina dolores william is also
here probably another copy made by
charlotte after the explosion at the
construction site here we have charlotte
teaching carriers how to dance in new
york just like delos trained the hosts
in westworld i wonder if this is a
flashback or not clementine is still
around but it looks like this woman
won't be for long this can't be good if
clementine is still under william's
control bernard and c investigate the
underground of what is likely the
abandoned 1920s park we also saw how it
was abandoned in his simulation
charlotte brings william to her
overwatch in the tower there's a map in
the center just like westworld had a map
in the mesa here's christina or dolores
we don't quite know under some water no
real clue as to what this is caleb's in
the same get-up we saw him in at the end
of episode 4 we'll see him try to escape
from a drone host william shoots an
unknown character maybe this is lawrence
after all he has been tracking down
other park hosts like clementine and
maeve a drone host inserts a pearl into
this weird machine could this be one of
the pearls that was smuggled out of
westworld at the end of season 2. you
can see someone blurred in the
background here it's a little too
difficult to make out we'll see this
machine in another shot in the
background as well as the season to come
trailer it looks like there's a device
which is put around someone's head in
this shot it looks as though someone is
controlling them via a touch pad i
wonder if this is any way related to the
device caleb had on his head at the
beginning of episode 4. caleb has found
himself in a very hot situation maybe
this is part of his escape from
captivity stubbs fights someone in a
futuristic grocery store where we'll
later see clementine i wonder if these
two will fight frankie and a drone host
in what may be new york we also get a
confrontation between maeve and
charlotte and maeve does not look to be
too happy holding that knife so that's
pretty much it for this week of
westworld i hope you enjoyed the video
and be sure to leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone and until next
time remember